much of the world is falling on economic
trouble times and france is no exception
this parisian fruit seller shows me
nectarines that are up 30 percent on
last year's prices
[Music]
it's because of rising oil and fuel
prices our produce is transported by
road so in the end the fruit prices rise
too and i think the war in ukraine also
has an effect
soaring inflation is making life more
expensive for voters who will elect a
new parliament next weekend they don't
blame the government but it will be the
government's job to sort it out
i understand that prices rise because
raw materials do but the government
needs to come up with solutions to have
fair prices for everyone so you don't
lose an arm and a leg every time you go
to the supermarket
first round voting has revealed that
emmanuel macron's centrists are at risk
of losing their parliamentary majority
while a leftist alliance is on the rise
and set to become the main opposition
whatever happens the centrists are
likely to find the business of
government far more difficult in
macron's second term than his first
france is not alone in its cost of
living crisis the rising cost of food of
energy of housing but there is a
confluence of things going on here a
steadily increasing voter apathy over
recent elections that if it's continued
next weekend could further support the
rise of the left in turn potentially
impeding the government's ability to
deal with the problems voters face
olivier polsky is a candidate for the
left-wing coalition challenging the
centrists for dominance of the national
assembly do you intend to disrupt
the project of emmanuel macron
oh yeah we're here for that
we want to raise salaries especially the
lowest one we want to freeze the prices
of essential goods and energy and we
want to send a strong message because
this is not the direction the government
is taking
the orientation
the rise of the left represents a
rebalancing of political forces in
france after years of dominance by
parties on the right but government will
not be more stable or effective for it
jonah al jazeera paris